[Music]
[Applause]
tom pelicero has been a busy guy nfl
insider you can follow him on twitter at
tom pelicero
and this sunday a special six hour
edition of nfl game day morning
airs at 9 00 a.m eastern on the nfl
network tom broke the news this morning
that nathaniel hackett the offensive
coordinator from the packers is going to
be the head coach of the denver broncos
tom thanks for joining us who is
nathaniel hackett and why did he get
this job
nathaniel hackett dan is a fascinating
guy he's 42 years old
he's been a longtime coach going all the
way back to his days uh in buffalo with
the bills at syracuse down in
jacksonville where i was in attendance
at heinz field after the 2017 season
when the jaguars with blake bortles at
quarterback put up 45 points on
pittsburgh to go to the afc championship
game uh he ended up
getting dismissed there the following
year amidst a whole bunch of injuries on
offense but landed in green bay with
matt lefleur and aaron rodgers and has
really flourished in his role these past
several years he's a unique individual
in terms of the way that he presents he
is very into
technology he's into analytics he's into
pop culture he finds different ways to
reach this generation of players and i
don't just mean you know the 20 21 year
old millennials or whatever we're
calling them but even the likes of aaron
rodgers who's a veteran quarterback has
heard it all for 20 plus years playing
football at every level and
rogers is one of hackett's biggest fans
to the point that
last year when hackett got his first
head coaching interview with the falcons
aaron rodgers called atlanta and said
you need to hire this guy so the fact
that now he's getting the broncos job at
a time that dan you might have heard
there are some questions about where
aaron rodgers we play in football in
2022 if anywhere it's a really good fit
for a bunch of different reasons and
i'll tell you this he's so high energy
nathaniel hackett is nobody's going to
fall asleep in his meetings he's going
to give the most entertaining press
conferences in the league and they think
he's going to win a lot of football
games for him too but i wonder you go in
in the interviewing process in denver
does john elway say
if we give you this job can we get aaron
rodgers like how how do you
would he get this job as standalone you
get the job to be fair to his resume and
how much is the possibility of getting
aaron rodgers attached to this
well as the broncos were going through
this process and general manager george
payton has been the one leading it
they knew that they couldn't hire a
coach based solely on a contingency that
may or may not happen of course last
year
denver was the most linked spot to aaron
rodgers rogers at various points told
people that denver was a place he wanted
to go he may have even thought that's
where he would potentially end up and
that was at a time you had vic fangio as
the head coach and pat shermer was the
offensive coordinator so now you have
hackett there he's going to in all
likelihood hire at least one packers
assistant adam cenovich who's the
offensive line coach run game
coordinator really well respected used
like 75 different o-line combinations
this year with baktiyari out uh and
managed to to make it work there's gonna
be familiarity there with the system
with the coaches uh it would only
heighten the possibility that rogers
could land there but they did a thorough
search you know peyton had
uh one of the most uh expansive search
parties they had i think seven people
who traveled around on the plane they
had other people involved on zoom they
had different perspectives uh from
different people and he spent time with
ten different candidates during the
process almost all of them
in person which is rare because in this
cycle one thing that came out of covid
was everyone was like hey the zoom thing
is great we'll just do a dozen or in the
bears case two dozen different
interviews all on zoom then we'll get to
the second interviews the broncos kind
of went old school fire up the private
jet we're going to go see 10 of these
coaches go all the way literally from
the east coast seeing rod mayo to the
west coast seeing kevin o'connell but
one of the first interviews that they
did was nathaniel hackett in green bay
peyton had dinner with him the night
before they spent a long time together
hackett after that initial interview had
so impressed them that he became one of
if not the front runner and so he was
the only one that they brought back for
a second interview on monday there's a
lot to like about nathaniel hackett for
the denver broncos beyond aaron rodgers
though certainly the rogers possibility
is a nice piece it feels like people
aren't on the same page with aaron
rodgers being able to leave the green
bay packers he's not a free agent
there would have to be a trade here and
i don't even know does aaron rodgers
have a no trade clause
he does not have a no trade clause
though effectively
you have one when you're at that stage
and you can just say if you try to trade
me to you know whatever jacksonville i'm
just gonna retire so really here's how
it sets up dan so they redid his
contract last year they shaved off they
didn't add any new money to it they
moved some things around but they shaved
off the last year in 2023 and they added
this post-super bowl void clause that in
essence means they can't tag aaron
rodgers after the 2022 season either so
really there's three different avenues
rogers can go he could retire that's
pretty clean the packers would save a
bunch of money on the salary cap uh he
could say i'm going to continue playing
for the packers at which point in all
likelihood that would involve the
packers and aaron rodgers doing some
kind of big fully guaranteed extension
that would keep him as a packer for life
or door number three is he could say you
know what it's been fun
i've had you know a ton of success here
over 17 years but it's time for me to do
something else the packers then at that
point would have two choices themselves
one being they could say
we're not trading you you're the
reigning two-time reigning nfl mvp
you're gonna play out your contract here
and rogers could say either okay i'll do
that or i you know we'll just decide to
walk away or the packers could go it's
in our best interest to trade aaron
rodgers when he's worth more right now
in terms of capital in players and picks
than he ever probably will be in the
rest of his career we'll trade him now
as opposed to he plays out his contract
in 2022 and then at most you're getting
like a fifth round compensatory pick in
2023 for him so it would set up a really
interesting situation he has that
control to dictate what direction what
the options are and then the packers
would have their own decision to make
yeah i just wonder i'm sure they want to
trade him to the afc
that sound right if you know if like
seattle if seattle wants to move on from
ross they probably want him in the afc
not the nfc
it would make sense and just for
historical context dan i was working for
the green bay press gazette in 2008
during the brett favre retirement saga
unretirement saga and all that stuff and
when he showed up in a lightning storm
in a helicopter and came in
in august during the family night
scrimmage showed up in his luxury box
during the scrimmage where rogers is
getting cheered when he throws in
completions and booed when he does
something well most bizarre scene ever
but there were two teams on brett favre
which were the new york jets and the
tampa bay buccaneers brett favre that
day after lengthy meetings with at the
time ted thompson mike mccarthy left the
facility thinking he's being traded to
the tampa bay buccaneers
comes to find out later that night that
ted thompson's trading them to the new
york jets and the jets had to recruit
him to go there part of that was ted
thompson who was one of brian goodkun's
mentors did not want brett favre in the
nfc that's not to say necessarily would
follow the same path but absolutely
that's something that that executives
take into account
what do you think sean payton's gonna do
he's gonna take some time away you know
he was after the season this was such a
trying season uh for sean payton and the
saints i mean you think about everything
they overcame from being displaced by a
hurricane in the early portion of the
season to jameis winston's injury to
other injuries to the covid situation
where they're down to starting ian book
in a in a nationally televised game
sean payton was wiped out by the end of
it so you know shortly after the season
ended he flew down to cabo he played
golf he drank tequila he
thought about his future and he came
back and he just thought i i need a
break uh you know in the short term
certainly he's going to have broadcast
options tv options he's you know i think
that his uh 35-minute opening monologue
to the press conference would probably
fit better on a podcast than in the 40
seconds you have between plays in a game
but sean would be exceptional at doing
that
he coaches because look jerry jones is
going to be 80 years of age
he has not
he's not given the stamp of approval for
mike mccarthy coming back
the timing of this is just too strange
why wait an extra year for sean payton
when you could get him now
and you give the saints money and or
picks and you got your coach a coach
that you've always wanted
you never say never because you also
know that other owners are looking at
this and going the time is now if we're
going to make a move for sean payton
we're at least going to place that phone
call i am choosing at this particular
stage and based on
the emotion that we saw from sean payton
the other day that he really is we can
take him at face value that his
intention of course intentions can
change but his intention is to take 2022
off and then that makes him one of the
most fascinating characters not just a
year from now but really throughout this
season i mean every time the team is in
a rut and we're talking about a coach
potentially being on the hot seat
there's going to be that cloud hanging
over of what might sean payton do dallas
is certainly a place that he's been
linked to i don't know how many times
throughout the course of his career but
there's going to be other places that
potentially are going to be in that mix
too and you look at some of the teams
that did not move on from their head
coaches this year and teams that did not
as strongly state publicly that they're
going to stick with their coach as
steven jones or the cowboys did with
mike mccarthy there's absolutely going
to be some coaches who are going to be
at risk of losing their jobs during next
season sean payton's going to be rumored
for every one of those openings and it
would be organizational malpractice dan
to not make a phone call on one of the
most successful coaches over the last 16
years yeah i just get a feeling that
sean is
the timing is just interesting
i mean you get a chance to coach the
cowboy that's different than any other
coaching
vacancy
or potential coaching vacancy you win in
dallas it's like being the cowboys
quarterback you may not be the best
quarterback in football but you're the
best known i mean you're the cowboys
quarterback you're the cowboys coach
i don't know and jerry is desperate to
get another super bowl
at 80 years of age
i don't i don't know
i don't know again i i would say
organizational malpractice if you're a
team that's even thinking about making a
coaching change to not place a call on
sean payton at the same time
i would tell you the support from the
joneses for mike mccarthy and his staff
is probably stronger internally than
it's perceived to be externally they
they went from six and ten in his first
year to twelve and five this season they
obviously made leaps they weren't
consistent enough offensively the
penalties were a problem in the in the
playoff game as they were throughout the
course of the season and they had some
frankly strange stuff happen with a play
that they've rehearsed a million times
over and now has become this supposed
example of that they don't they're
poorly coached and everything else they
practice that every friday it's the same
scenario they timed it out they just
never rehearsed having the umpire be 28
yards behind the play and then come and
run over their quarterback on the way to
spotting the ball and re-spotting it and
spotting it again
it's again i'm not saying that you
couldn't have called something different
there but based upon that look where the
nose tackles lined up everything that
they did was exactly how they rehearsed
it it didn't work out it doesn't
completely erase the fact they went 12-5
this season and should be good for years
to come
thank you tom we appreciate you joining
us and uh congrats on breaking the uh
hackett to the broncos news we'll wait
for you to break other news like sean
payton to the cowboys
thanks for having me thank you tom
that's tom pelacero nfl network insider
you can follow him at tom pellicer does
a great job
probably doesn't get enough credit for
the job that he does